The idea was
solving social problems
is different than solving business
problems.
It takes strategy,
it takes research,
it takes careful analysis,
but it also takes a different set of
tools and we saw a lot of terrific tools
being developed in the business context
to make companies competitive and
profitable and successful.
We didn't see a similar set of tools
being as widely developed in the
nonprofit sector and so we wanted to
create a firm that brought the same kind
of analysis and strategy and reasoning
and research into solving social issues
for foundations,
for nonprofits and for corporations.
We often deal with funders,
charitable funders,
whether it's foundations or private
foundations or corporate foundations or
even individual philanthropists.
And one of the first barriers is the
fact that people don't really expect to
solve social problems through their
philanthropy.
They would like to pick a good cause,
a worthy organization,
give that organization money and that's
a great thing to do.
But there's a real problem with our
nonprofit sector today in this country.
You know,
we have the most vibrant,
most creative,
largest nonprofit sector in the world.
And yet,
when you look at where the United States
stands on social issues,
on things like education,
things like healthcare,
things like the environment,
we're at the bottom of the list of
developed countries.
So somehow on the one hand we have this
wonderful nonprofit sector and on the
other hand,
we're not solving the problems that the
nonprofit sector is supposed to be
solving.
So there's a real basic problem there
and we believe the problem really has to
do with the behavior of donors that
donors are not expecting or demanding
results.
They aren't being realistic and
strategic in their giving to actually
try and solve the problem.
And without that incentive,
nonprofits respond to the way donors
think currently rather than focus in on
how can they actually achieve a
meaningful impact on
the organization that they should
choose.
Um,
I,
I guess the best way to think about it
is a,
we did a very interesting engagement for
the gates foundation and they came to us
and they said we'd like to help
encourage more effective philanthropy.
Not more money,
but more effective practices,
but we're not really sure what that
means.
So what does it mean to be effective in
philanthropy?
And so they asked us to go out and
interview a couple dozen donors,
high net worth donors,
people who give away at least a million
dollars a year,
but people who are perceived as being
highly effective in their philanthropy.
And to be honest,
we didn't think this engagement going to
work because we were talking to all
kinds of donors,
you know,
men,
women,
young,
old,
inherited wealth,
real estate,
new technology all across the country.
But we actually found something very
interesting that all of these donors
came into philanthropy.
They were responding to requests.
They were being a good citizen.
They didn't really see any impact for
their money.
They could give away millions of dollars
and nothing seemed to change and they
were kind of discouraged and at some
point they came across an issue that had
real urgency and real personal
significance to them.
So in one case,
someone son had a rare brain disease and
there wasn't much research.
In another case,
there was a beautiful theater downtown
that was going to be torn down as a
development.
And what happened was they stopped
thinking about how do I give away money?
And they started thinking about how do I
solve a specific problem and it changed
completely how they went about things.
So instead of saying which charity do I
write a check to or so on,
they said,
what would have to happen for this
problem to be solved and how can we take
responsibility for making those things
happen?
And it's really this problem solving
approach to philanthropy that we see as
the core difference between effective
philanthropists and most of the very
well meaning well intentioned people out
there who given away a lot of money but
aren't really seeing.